Computers first took up
an entire room.
Then they fit on your
desk.
Then the next thing you
knew, they were portable
folding devices that
could sit on your lap.
Since then, laptops have
become even smaller and
more lightweight, yet
more and more powerful.
With its lightning fast
processor and dazzling
graphics. This laptop is
designed for high
performance gaming.
And if that's not cool
enough, you can light up
the keyboard in a choice
of nearly 17 million
colors. The computer's
brain.
The motherboard begins
as a printed circuit
board. Its pattern of
lines and pads and copper
is the wiring for the
electronic components
that will be soldered to
the board.
This machine places a
stencil of the component
layout onto the board
and applies solder paste
through the openings.